I live in Iowa in the midst of severe flooding in the past month. My 21-year-old son has been
doing clean-up, taking out dogs, deconstructing buildings, cleaning out toxic, boldly sewage-filled
basements. His boss advised him to get a tetashot. I believe the tetas vaccine is only available in a
DPT. He has had no vaccines ever. What are your thoughts on ways to protect against tetas?
And what are some natural ways to boost and protect your body in such conditions?
Yeah, I am not in favor of getting the vaccine. I'm not in favor of getting a tetas, even if you're
exposed. Know that you're going to possibly be exposed to tetas. There's a giant discussion involved
in that. The good websites to go to about vaccines would be vaccine awareness. I forgot the name
of it. Robert Kennedy's website, vaccines can be beneficial. The best ways to boost your body
is through protection. So you boost your immune system to immune stimulants. And he's got to be
wearing masks and clothing and things. So you deal in especially with the moldy sewage,
just being on the basements. The best way to protect yourself is through protecting exposure,
giving yourself barriers.